wow
wow oh my god i i
am so surprised by this news this is uh
really surprising i i just heard that
jared leto is going to be
returning as joker for justice league i
was going to actually shoot a different
dc video today
and then i'm like what this what what
where did this come from
there's so many other actors who are
already returning obviously to do
i think some actual reshoots and some
just to do some voiceover work
i don't know who really saw this piece
of news
coming jere leto's joker from suicide
squad is such a
debated performance some people defend
it some people really don't like it
some people saw the extended cut not the
david haircut
i am still opting for hashtag release
the aircut
i really want to see that version and
david ayer is really championing to get
that version out there in the public as
well so i really want that version with
jared leto
i do fall on the side where i'm not that
big of a fan of the performance
that being said if there is an air cut
to ever be released i'd
absolutely watch it as soon as it's out
especially because david ayer really
defends the hell
out of jared leto's joker he's gone on
record many times essentially saying
that if we saw that performance we would
really like his portrayal
a hell of a lot more so to see him here
in the snyder cut i don't
recall any piece of news from the past
saying
anything along the lines and maybe there
is i mean i'd be curious to know you
could leave it down in the comments i
don't recall anyone in the past
saying that jared leto's joker was
supposed to be
in the original version of justice
league so i don't know if this is
something new they're coming up with i
don't know if this is a fulfilling and
original vision to take place i can't
imagine though
that this is supposed to be you know a
big
role i i just can't it already seems
like there's so many other
bigger things that have been left
unfinished with the snyder cut
that that's what we have to go check out
that's what we have to really tune in
for
if anything i imagine this is probably a
smaller rule this is probably a cameo
right i
i do know that in the snyder code
trailer that came out of dc fandom some
people did point out that you do see the
joker calling card at one point during
the apocalyptic
sequence course of birds of prey he was
alluded to
many times throughout that film and you
see like
a double playing him but you never see
the face even in space jam 2 there's
someone who's playing the version of
jared leto's joker
while i you know not a big fan of his
specific portrayal at least from the
versions that we've seen of him doing it
i'm of course excited to see whatever it
is that he has to do i'm
super jacked for the snyder cut to come
out and i wonder what the
purpose of him being here is i'm maybe
it could be a flashback maybe if zack
snyder wants to do a complete
wrap-around really put a final stamp on
the zack snyder versions of the dc films
you know because there was that big
thing in batman v superman with the bat
suit that says haha jokes on you batman
what's the real story behind all that so
maybe we'll see a flashback that talks
about it maybe joker will play some
significant part in helping to conquer
the mission and my question is though
would
jared leto's joker making an appearance
here be a saving grace for his
performance
will him having a scene or two because i
can't imagine he will be
a main character here but will whatever
scene he has in here
be enough for the audiences who weren't
so endeared by his performance to go you
know what
we should give jared leto's joker a
second chance maybe he can shine enough
in the snyder cut for us to go hey we
should get that air cut now
let's see all the things that david
air's been talking about of what has
made jared leto's joker that much better
i know jared leto has talked publicly
he's essentially felt robbed from
allowing his performance to really
shine but i'm willing to give the guy a
second chance i want to see the haircut
i want to see more footage of him i'm so
amped for whatever the hell they're
going to be doing with the snyder cut
that whatever they do with him here i'm
just glad that his time as the joker is
not just getting that unfortunate axe
because regardless of whatever
it is that we thought of the performance
and like i said i wasn't a big fan
there's no denying that jared leto
generally is a pretty
amazing actor there's no denying that he
really did
work his ass off on that role that he
went full on method to give the best he
could do whether or not that clicked
with an audience or not
he really gave it his all so i want to
see more of what he has to offer so i'm
not sure what the purpose of
him being in here is maybe it can be
used enough to be a saving grace for
jared leto decided we could finally see
that joker and harley quinn movie that's
been talked about for years
maybe this can push to get the air cut
to come out there who knows maybe it'll
just be a
fine scene and maybe it was like all
right that was that was cool he was
there
either way i'm actually excited for the
guy
guys what do you think about this piece
of news are you excited that jared
leto's going to be returning leave your
thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit the like button do whatever you want
leave all your thoughts down below
thanks for being here
[Music]